تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها دمرت اثنتين
واربعين طائره مسيره فوق شبه جزيره القرم
في الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم اضافه
الوزاره ان قوه الدفاع الجوي دمرت تسعه
طائرات مسيره بينما تم تدميره
عن طريق التشويش الالكتروني حيث تم
تحطيمها دون ان تصل الى اهدافها
كما قال الجيش الروسي في وقت مبكر من
اليوم ان اوكرانيا حاولت مهاجمه اهداف
مدنيه على الاراضي الروسيه بصاروخ معدل من
طراز اسمئتين فقلت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان منظومات الدفاع الجوي دمرت المقذوفه
فوق منطقه كالوجا المتاخمه لموسكو
وقد ادى الهجوم بالصواريخ الى تعليق
الطيران في جميع مطارات موسكو بشكل مؤقت
قبل ان تعلن الوكاله الروسيه للنقل الجوي
استئناف العمل فيها بشكل طبيعي بدءا من
الساعه الثامنه صباحا